hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren mord vorstellungen erst mal es
war ja gestern weihnachten deswegen ist
das noch mal so ein zweites
weihnachtsgeschenk an euch neben diesen
20 acts video in minecraft und ich hoffe
meine stimme ist schon ein bisschen
besser geworden und ich habe jetzt einen
kompressor mischpult deswegen ich hoffe
dass man das hört hört sich das jetzt
besser an von der soundqualität schreibt
von die kommentare ich möchte diesen
passt ein bisschen weg haben den ich in
der letzten zeit so ein bisschen drin
hatte deswegen schreibt für eine
kommentare ob ich der sound so gefällt
und diesem ort beinhaltet breaking bad
breaking bad ist für mich noch richtig
richtig geile serie guckt einfach bei
irgendwelchen illegalen internet stream
plattform hat spaß guckt euch die folge
kauft euch die staffel im laden staffel
1 bis 5 deutlich gibt es mittlerweile
über 60 folge mittlerweile mit ward
arbeit mit skyler mit ganz vielen
anderen personen wolter wald ist der
hauptcharakter ist der hauptcharakter
das geil ich weiß gar nicht so genau wer
da wäre jetzt mehr anteile hat volta ist
einfach und personen der die bisschen
älter ist und er hat dann einfach so ein
drogen labor eröffnet weil er geld
braucht um irgendwie seine krankheits
kacke dazu bezahlen und eventuell in das
ganze nicht klappt also wenn ihr dann
irgendwie doch steht um seine wenn seine
behandlung dann nicht klappt wenn du das
nicht bezahlen kann
um geld für seine familie zu unterlegen
und nach der zeit freuen die sich da nie
was heißt anfreunden also die am kontakt
zum drogenboss und bla bla bla bla bla
wenn ihre genaueres wissen könnte es ja
nur ein schreibe ich will das jetzt
nicht alles boilern die sache ist also
das mit dem mischpult erstmal meine
stimme ist an sich schon mega kacke
angeschlagen wegen erkältung und
deswegen halte den unterschied
wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal noch nicht
so krass aber ich finde es auf jeden
fall schon mal geil erstmal hatte habe
ich mir um natürlich das passende viele
herzustellen die web heruntergeladen
dies ist die white residenz also das
haus von white
dieses major junior hockey in memory of
michael succow hektoliter
und da ich hier sagt verkaterte baum
diese skulptur
na gut das ist so diewald residenz ich
zeige euch jetzt mal ganz kurz auf den
hintern sondern so einen pool mit seinem
unterhaltungs tischen platz blabla
dateien fenster da man kann davon hier
reingehen
eigentlich sollte man das nicht sondern
den haupteingang kommen dem benutzer den
haupthahn weil wir einfach die bahn bus
sind also ich habe dieses video
beinhaltet einmal diese map die steht in
der beschreibung und auch eine crystal
meth motto da steht noch eine andere web
in der beschreibung zwar eine breaking
bad adventure map die möchte euch
nämlich auch noch hier anschließend
gleich noch kurz zuvor stellen damit das
video jetzt nicht ganz so kurz in berlin
es gibt noch eine breaking bad und dies
auch erst vor kurzem von monat
herausgekommen dass eine crystal meth
wort also der stellt hier crystal meth
her nicht in die lsd kokain irgendwas
anderes kokain kann es überhaupt
herstellen kurz dass ich kann mich nicht
so aus betrogen ist auch gut so
und ja das hier ist erstmal ein haus für
ein paar wochen das fernweh
das ist ein kamin ich weiß gar nicht so
genau
ich glaube das ist ich glaube es ist im
fernseher also glaube ich jetzt mal weil
ihr bänke blablabla barhocker
das soll die küche da stelle ich hab ein
paar sachen verändert ich hab den
kräften table hingehauen und jede kiste
mit kohle warum werdet ihr gleich noch
sehen und hier ist eigentlich nicht der
crest ihre crystal meth bahn weil das
eigentlich sehr ich sag mal versteckt
ist es gibt auch eine eine person die
eine das crystal meth das versteckte
crystal meth dabei unter der erde von
worldwide nachgebaut hat allerdings hat
die davon nur spielstadt hochgeladen
ich blende euch jetzt einfach mal oben
links die ganze zeit ein paar
screenshots einen davon das ist echt das
sieht echt hammer hammer hammermäßig
geil aus konnte ich mir allerdings nicht
runterladen weil er keinen download
veröffentlicht hat sonst hätte ich das
selbstverständlich da gemacht das wäre
so was von episch gewesen das ist der
einzige walter white house oder
irgendwas mit breaking bad zu tun haben
der downloadshop es gibt noch diesem
trakt einmal dieses aus der pilotfolge
hat folgen weiß nicht jetzt schon so
lange her
die serie doch mehrere grammys bekommen
was egal wir fangen jetzt einfach mal
mit der modifikation an und zwar führt
diese modifikation drei teams hinzu das
ist einmal dieser christoph block der
auch in höhlen et cetera sport das jetzt
allerdings gerade eine map die wenn ihr
mal schaut jetzt bedrock und naja die
map ist ein bisschen klein deswegen kann
ich euch hier keine höhlen zeigen dass
hier richtig zu sowie im prinzip
wegschmeißen vier minuten durchziehen
jetzt hier jedenfalls fügt er halt diese
ganzen sachen hinzu diese aber diesen
wenn ich einfach mal ne fein gebe man
diesen block dann das messeteam weit das
was wir daraus bekommt also die red star
gast in etwa oder lapis und dann mit
nach und das ist wenn man das verbrennt
ich geh jetzt mal kurz in dem game zu
null
und ihr seht schon ich kann das mit
allen sachen abbauen ist nur andere
geschwindigkeit gold ist relativ schnell
gold sogar schneller als eisen fata und
diamant deshalb auch relativ schnell ich
glaub gold geht sogar im schnellsten
gold gold gold diamanten gold am
schnellsten und ich müsste jetzt genau
okay hier seht ihr unten drin
ich trinke alkohol den drei stück raus
ist immer so jetzt kommt 33 36 42 und 45
soll das habe ich 45 von diesem teil
nicht im bett einfach meine kohle
verteilers thema geben kurz und packe
ich ja eben was rein und hier und gleich
werdet ihr schon sehen das ist also die
sachen nutzen sich hier halte ich normal
ab das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
verändert oder so wie ihr seht gleich
schon warum ich milch im inventar hab
einfach mal rein meth und ihr braucht
nicht mal nach und haben also warum
haben wir können das auch einfach so
essen und achtet man jetzt komplett
normal jetzt als ich dieses match
dingsbums hallo macht macht die effekte
drauf da okay ich weiß nicht war aber
gut ich kriege jetzt hunger
geschwindigkeit stärke übelkeit und
resistenz also ich bin sogar ständig an
übelkeit das ist alles
cannes ist die kür schlagen dass ich
wichtig da brauche wenn überhaupt
treffen zwei punches mit beschwert sich
dass es gar nicht austesten aber es ist
halt einfach ich hab stärke ich habe als
möglicher seid einfach wie man die wenn
man drogen nimmt man denkt man sei
irgendwann könnte fliegen et cetera das
wäre cool wenn ich jetzt mal wie fliegen
könnte oder so also ganz hohe jobs
machen oder so das der grund warum ich
jetzt auch nicht dabei habe weil ganz
einfach wenn man nicht trinkt ist dieser
effekt weg und das ist auch ein fact
übrigens auch vorstellen wie jetzt
gerade gesehen da kamen diese ändern
wenn man aus dem neckar zurückkommt kam
dieser portal effekt dass es auch wenn
man milch trinkt und irgendwie übelkeit
vorher drauf hat sie also ihr könnt
damit relativ leicht sachen machen das
eigentlich keine so geile nabu aus der
sein team wie in dem kampf mit richtig
vielen zombies und hab dann diamant
schwert und dieses mass dingsbums und
könnten einfach ein bisschen neuhaus
schneller panschen also die macht an
sich ist sehr sehr sehr sehr klein ich
wollte erst allgemeine drogen mord
vorstellen allerdings finde ich dass
drogen mit allgemeinen nicht so gut zu
breaking bad passt oder meine crystal
meth j und dann habe ich dann auch hier
einfach die map genommen da das ganze
jetzt ein bisschen wenig werden wollte
ich euch auch noch eben die breaking bad
adventure web vorstellen wo auch der
download link in der beschreibung ist
und zwar kann man hier dann klickt man
hat hier noch ein paar sachen und kann
sich dann hier irgendwie zurecht braunen
hier irgendwie kann ich das da rein
packen dann braucht der medizin frank
das machte fermentierte spinnen auch ich
weiß gar nicht was da rauskommt ich habe
ich nicht so gut aus mit dem sie mit
braun
allerdings können oder das im buch krieg
gegen kommentar der bringen dafür dabei
6666 oft matthew ich muss jetzt also
sind ein paar sachen seine kleine
enttäuschen werde ich zeige euch das mal
ganz kurz
man sieht hier verschiedene räume man
wird dann immer hin und her teleportiert
beziehungsweise muster hinlaufen sieht
dann auch das sind nur die eps schätzung
wir haben da hinten dorf was aber
einfach nur so gespannt ist und als ein
paar sachen wo man dann immer mappus das
weiß doch jetzt habe ich irgendwie
kannte gemacht wo halt so ein paar
sachen sind die man dann
ab und zu bewältigen muss ein bisschen
braun die labour plane man eine bombe
keine ahnung ich sterbe hier ja fast ihr
müsst das ganze selbst herausfinden
ich werde kein let's play von elisabeth
machen weil die halt sehr sehr kurz ist
wo wir verwenden
ich habe mein herz an herz ist das sieht
mega creepy muss das erstmal hier ist
diese straße
diese straße wo das alles passiert ist
jesse also ihr seht schon das ist
eigentlich ganz sehr gut sehr gut durch
plan noch relativ neu mit command blogs
oben links müsste fertig sein
dank der schwäche oft gar nicht hin ich
glaube dann sollte ich eigentlich auch
irgendwie anwerfen und jetzt habe ich
schwäche na gut egal im freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über einen daumenbruch freuen
wenn ihr weitere videos haben wollt
schreibt wir nochmal einerseits in die
kommentare mods die ich eventuell noch
vorstellen sollten welche downloads und
was auch sehr wichtig ist schreibt mir
mal in die kommentare was eure lieblings
serie ist weil jetzt gerade sogar die
ferien über die feiertage denke ich mir
immer so okay ich bin zu hause
ich mache hier täglich zwei videos
manchmal auch drei videos und ich möchte
einfach noch etwas anderes machen und
ich brauche ihn die neue serie die ich
gucken kann der braking bag bin ich
jetzt bald durch danach werde ich mir
wahrscheinlich sogar etwas zulegen und
da die ganzen serien gucken also
richtiger serienjunkie werden schreibt
mir einfach mal ein paar gute serien in
den kommentaren darauf meldet weil da
kenne ich alle folgen die neuen folgen
wenn ich mich angucken schreibt einfach
irgendwie scrubs walking walking dead
nicht so gar nicht mal so geil obwohl
die serie auf mit eine menge preise
bekommen hat hat aber sonst schon als
auch ein bisschen weiter meine stimme
schreiben einfach eure lieblings serien
einfach in die kommentare und dann kann
ich in der nächsten woche zeigen was
daran so aus kam
schreibt einfach eure lieblings er ihn
rein und dann würde ich sagen downloads
und in der beschreibung beim nächsten
mal wieder macht's gut und schön